all right guys
bang bang i've got a special guest here
peter
has joined us thank you so much for
doing this sir happy to do it
for sure let's just jump right into your
background um kind of what you did
before
uh you joined uh and started horizon
kinetics
sure my first professional uh job was
working at
bankers trust company which ultimately
got acquired by deutsche bank i worked
in the
trust department or the investment
advisory department
and i was a portfolio manager there and
i worked there for approximately a
decade
and we left there as a group myself and
a number of individuals and started a
company called horizon asset management
in 1994 and then two years later i
started the second company called
kinetics asset management
and the idea was that i was going to use
the research and analytical capabilities
of horizon
to build up the kinetics business and
the kinetics business has the
distinction of
being the first company to start an
internet mutual fund in the
in the united states got it and so
where did the names horizon asset
management and kinetics asset management
those those two are known now as horizon
kinetics but where did those two names
come from
sure that's a group that's a great
question it gets into our investment
philosophy on the on the horizon side
horizon is meant to be long horizon look
out
into the future and one of the things
that we observed
my colleague deserved it and other
people had observed it as well
is that if you extend your time horizon
based on how the financial industry is
structured i.e everyone's looking at
calendar year
results what you find is that the market
will discount certain securities at a
very high rate
because it doesn't fall within that very
discrete time period that most
investment managers are looking for
i need something that's going to do well
in the year 2020
if i think it's going to do well in the
year 2021 22 it has
little utility to me so that was meant
to show that we're
long-term value-oriented investors
horizon
in the case of kinetics it's a name that
my brother picked up just a
dealing with energy and things of that
nature so he's the one who came up with
that
got it and then uh how do we get to
horizon kinetics today
so we went through the financial crisis
and there's a lot of confusing
confusion in the marketplaces why is
this product over and horizon why is
this product over in kinetics
it just made sense to basically
consolidate the two businesses
bring them under one roof and run it
that way
got it and maybe talk a little bit just
you started to mention the investment
thesis being longer term
focused kind of how do you describe the
interest that you guys have and the
assets and industries that you look at
kind of what is that investment thesis
or that investment philosophy
so before we even put pen to paper to
determine whether or not something is
good or not
you have to think through the
qualitative aspects of a business
so what what is the product is this
product
have a long product life cycle is it
going to be demanded 5 years from now 10
years from now 20 years from now
so if you think about berkshire hathaway
buying geico
auto insurance it was needed 50 years
ago it's going to be needed
you know in another 20 years so what's
his advantage
i can provide that auto insurance
generally at 15 less because i'm going
direct to the consumer
so he understands that business he says
i want that long
product life cycle business that's
really kind of what we're thinking about
we're like we want to compound our money
we want to capture the business returns
and we want the businesses themselves to
have a
high degree of predictability and that
and that's really our goal and then
paying a price that's we think we're
going to get that reasonable rate of
return
absolutely and so obviously being value
investors kind of the price you pay
is a big determinant to the return
you're gonna get
um maybe let's just start with the macro
environment
uh it's tough being a value investor uh
right now
um how have you guys looked at the macro
environment
um you know kind of before covid then
when coveted hit and then the fed's
response afterwards
so we recognized pretty early i would
say that
um we probably even picked up during the
greenspur
greenspan era of the greenspan put
saying okay there's a lot of debt
building up in the in the
economy a lot of debt building up on
balance sheets etc
and it seems like anytime there's a
problem they're willing to step in
obviously the financial crisis you saw
that the federal reserve was willing to
step in in a big way
and it became really obvious to us that
there was a point of no return
so you can go through the you know the
national debt of the united states right
now is at 27 trillion dollars the
total debt of the entire country is
something like 80 trillion dollars
if you start thinking about what it
would mean to refinance that two
percentage points higher three
percentage points higher
it would choke off the economy very
quickly so we obviously didn't see covet
19 come
on was predictable and in our opinion
coming out of the financial crisis we
felt that the
federal reserve was kind of locked in a
position where they're going to keep
interest rates for
a long period of time we're talking
possibly multiple decades
and that was pre-covered now it's that
now it's a guarantee you saw what
happened at the end of 2018 the
quantitative tightening that they tried
two and a half three weeks market traded
down 20
percent and they quickly reversed
themselves
so my guess is that they're going to
they recognize the problem there's a
debt problem in this country there's a
debt problem globally and
central banks around the world are going
to keep rates down artificially low
and they're going to try to inflate you
out of their money to pay you back in
cheaper dollars
so that's that's kind of how we saw the
backdrop now couple that with
the rise of etfs and indexation
and there's nothing wrong with
indexation
in fact it makes a lot of sense at a
certain price
the problem with indexation is that the
more money that flows into a particular
index they buy the same securities now
it may make perfectly great sense that
10 times earnings
it makes reasonable sense at 15 times
earning you start buying at 30 40 times
earnings makes no sense you're not going
to get a good return you're going to
probably lose money over a 10-year
period of time
so that was really that's kind of the
headwind that the
value investor has been facing for the
last decade plus
and it's you know i like to say it's
pure insanity um but so far it's been
working out that way and money continues
to flow in
i think ultimately i think we're at a
tipping point i think the
scale of it is so large the that they're
not ever going to get 100 of that
and if you look at the s p 500 as an
example the top five names represent
25 26 it defeats the purpose of
indexation
you don't want that concentration you
wanted to buy the asset class you wanted
to get the
long-term return on the asset class now
you're making a bet on a handful of
things
and i think people are going to
recognize that i think certainly
standard employers recognize that
investor all the people that put out
these products are
saying okay this is not really achieving
its goal and i think it's it's going to
end up being a real problem for people
so
we're about as far away from that as you
can possibly be
and and so describe a little bit in
terms of like where that puts you right
so if you're not doing indexing and kind
of all the passive investing and
uh where exactly are you looking for uh
investment ideas for putting capital
so one of the things that we talked
about that i meant just mentioned was
the probability of inflation i.e the
government needing to inflate their way
out of that out of the
debt crisis and so we're looking at hard
assets
and tangible assets and asset like
companies so when i meet when i'm
when i say something like hard assets
we're looking at
a company that derives its revenues from
the underlying commodity
but doesn't necessarily have a business
operations attached to that so a royalty
company
so there's a handful of companies like
that maybe 10 globally
we own all of those companies and those
companies have extraordinary rates of
returns from a business operations
standpoint
they rival the best monopolistic
businesses
around in terms of operating profits and
net profits
can you give us an example of one of
those sure
one of the biggest positions of ours is
a company called texas pacific land
trust and it's been around since the
1880s
nobody knows about it it is
unquestionably
the most valuable piece of real estate
in the world and they they
collect royalty on a certain number of
acres about 456
000 acres and they collect a royalty
interest so if chevron wants a drill on
that they pay them a royalty check
and then they own about another 900 000
acres of surface acreage
so if anyone wants to drill in the
permian basin in delaware basin they
need to cross onto texas-pacific land
trust land
and they pay them a royalty so
essentially the check cashing business
and it's been around since 1888 and it's
quietly taking itself
private it has paid dividends over the
passage of time it's also acquired its
stock
so when we looked at the underlying
value and the developments in technology
on fracking we said okay the fracking
technology continues to improve they've
only scratched the surface
at a very small amount of what the
amount of oil that's in there there's an
ocean of oil under the effect ground
and they're going to collect ever larger
royalty checks in the future
so the price of oil from the year 2014
through today
in 2014 it was 114 dollars
it's now down around 40 west texas
intermediate of
oil you made four and a half times your
money in
texas pacific land trust that's with oil
being down very substantially
if you ever had the wind at your back
oil went up you can see how you can make
a lot of money so
we're really the only company that you
can get any type of meaningful exposure
to that
to that business and it's ranks on if
you look at the long-term stock returns
of texas-specific land trust
it's among the best on the new york
stock exchange going back 50 60 70 years
yeah that's really really interesting
and it sounds like you guys
are uh pretty convinced that the fed's
actions right they've publicly stated
they're gonna shoot for
over two percent for some persistent
amount of time in the inflation
um it sounds like you have confidence
that they will actually be able to do
that
or are you more playing the fact that
just them saying it drives inflation
fears and therefore
uh kind of there's the flow of capital
into inflation hedge assets
well for us is is if everyone has their
money
in the high growth tech companies etc
we're saying what if you're not 100
certain you're not going to be 100 right
what do you think there's a one percent
chance that you're going to be wrong
maybe you should allocate one percent to
us because we're a safeguard against
that world
coming apart the cpi has been
manufactured
and they can come up with a number
whatever they really want and they've
reconfigured it a number of times and
the way they formally use it calculated
cpi has been running at about six
percent
and if you look at the things that you
really desire in life that's probably
running
at 10 11 and if you look at the money
printing that's going on
it's running at 15 20 percent more
recently but it's been running
historically mq has been increasing
about six or seven percent which is a
good benchmark for the inflation rate so
if you
if you look at a 10-year treasury
you're getting 78 basis points today the
stated mandate is to get inflation up to
2
that means your real return is going to
be negative in all likelihood
and if you really look through these
stated numbers to what's really
important
you see that the inflation rate is
substantially higher than that so let me
just i
want to digress one sec just to show you
how how the inflation is
going through the economy and affecting
people
so when they bring interest rates down
to near zero
financial institutions make their money
banks make spread
insurance companies make money on their
investment portfolio
so i have homeowners insurance and now
the homeowner insurance they know they
collect a premium for me
many times they're looking to collect
the premium and break even and they're
going to make it on the float
right that's how warren buffett became a
multi multi billionaire he's earning
money on
tens of trillions tens of billions of
dollars with no cost so now they bring
it down to zero they say okay i can't
make money in my investment portfolio
i'm going to have to charge you
substantially more for your homeowners
insurance so my homeowner's insurance
policy
is up 20 year-over-year so that's
inflation that's a real expense i'm not
going to give up home on this insurance
so
people aren't appreciating that so
unless you have re you know
upped your home on insurance you haven't
noticed that inflation yet but that's
coming that's around the corner for most
people
and so when you think through this um it
feels like
the fed has to bring you know i keep
calling like a monetary stimulus
bomb to the table in order to get
inflation anywhere near this two percent
official number right cause i'm with you
in that the
uh the unofficial numbers are much worse
than are being reported
uh everyone doesn't experience the same
level of inflation right which is a
whole nother
kind of can of worms but in order to get
the cpi numbers up over two percent
it feels like they've almost brought
like this water gun to
a pistol fight right in that they've got
rates down to zero
they've printed a good amount of of
money but
it doesn't feel like we're gonna get
there with what they've already done so
what do they do do they go negative
rates do they just
print and print and print we see 10
trillion dollars more like how do we get
to that
two plus percent in the official numbers
that they're targeting
so i i don't think they ever really care
if we get there or not to be honest with
you i think the plan is that oh we're
trying so hard to do it let us print up
more money and we'll inflate you more at
it
and pay back in cheaper dollars the debt
burden that we have um
so that that's kind of my take on that
i would say that you know if the things
that i mentioned
like the chalkboard index the things
that you really desire the inflation
rate is running at much much higher
levels than that and they're also going
to do fiscal stimulus right so
the bill is likely to pass and after
they get done with their squabbling in
the next month or so
they're going to spend another 1.8 2
trillion dollars that are going to go
into
repairs and they'll start doing those
types of things and they
and the federal reserve and will
monetize that they won't call it
monetary but it's basically going to be
spending they'll send checks to people's
homes et etc to get people to spend
yeah and the fiscal side to me
everyone's focused on the monetary side
because that's the ones that have the
really clear-cut numbers that's the ones
that everyone writes about
uh over the last couple of months coming
out of the covid kind of you know market
crash
uh but the fiscal stuff almost seems
more dangerous right would you agree
with that or do you think that they're
kind of both
you know equal well that's that's where
you can see the real spending so if they
said
if they send a check directly to your
home it's not oh
it's sitting on the bank the banks are
better capitalized they don't need to
lend out the money
it's coming into my pocket i'm going out
and i'm going to spend that money
you know typical americans going to do
that they need to do that
i think now because there's so many
people behind in arrears on their
mortgages
in their rents
so you know for the first time in my
life
i really came to the conclusion that
capitalism is broken here in this
country
and you know it used to be if i took
risk and i made a mistake and my
adjustment was bad i was going to get
knocked in the teeth with that and
i take my losses i you know earlier this
year
i made a bet about being short
volatility and it obviously went against
me fairly dramatically
in in march and april and then i started
to de-leverage my portfolio and i see
that the federal reserve is stepping in
and buying bonds i said i don't need to
sell these bonds
so they went from being down 20 to
basically being up 10 12
in in a couple weeks time and that
that's a problem
that's a moral hazard uh for investors
so i don't see how they're getting out
of this um
and i think they're going to see this
spin like they have been and i think
it's going to accelerate
and and you know it for the first time
in my life i said what is the charade
of me paying taxes if you can just print
up money out of thin air why am i paying
taxes just print up a little extra more
you know and pay my taxes for me you
know just add it to the tab
so it's a problem this is a really
important point and i think that uh when
people first started saying it was kind
of the
smart asses on twitter and stuff like
that and everyone just kind of
disregarded it because it was coming
from people who
don't manage capital don't spend a lot
of time on you know kind of talking
about the economy
uh you are probably the 10th or 12th
person who
uh runs a large asset management firm
that has i've had this conversation with
and my point to people is it's one thing
when it's a student anonymous account on
twitter kind of looking for
retweets and memes and all that kind of
stuff it's another thing when you start
to get kind of the
the most sophisticated investors in a
market saying wait a second
what's going on here right what's the
end game like
where are we headed and also why are
there certain things like
the tax collection etc going on does
that
feel like that's a new talk track or a
new focus for investors in your opinion
or is this something that's maybe been
going on forever
and people just didn't talk about it um
i think the dead burden
there was always hope that new
technologies were going to lead to
growth in the economy
you're going to grow your way out of
this and you could handle the dead
burden i think it's got to the point
where that's not
an option anymore and they're going to
continue to print up or spend what they
need to spend so it's the first time
that i ever thought about it's the first
time in my life where
i really said this is this is not right
you know what they're doing to
the typical saver to the typical
investor in there
you know if i made a mistake i was
always happy to basically
take the hit and okay i learned from
that let's move on you know i'm not
going to be right on all things
and i think they really created a
situation where they're not going to be
able to get out of that and they're just
going to continue to devalue and devalue
it
at a faster and faster rate yeah
when you think about kind of what's
going on now i think you and i see eye
to eye that this is not good
where does this end up is this a default
situation
is this hyperinflation of the dollar is
there some other scenario that kind of
you see as the natural
end state uh if they kind of continue
doing what they're doing
i i think they're just going to continue
to you know take a decade or two decades
or three decades
three decades to basically grow their
throw their way out of this and
pay back the debt in cheaper and cheaper
dollars um so i i'm not sure that it's
going to be
a doomsday scenario um i think you need
to protect yourself against that
and um i think you know obviously you're
a believer in bitcoin i'm a believer in
bitcoin i think that's one of the ways
that you can protect yourself against
that
yeah so you it sounds like you actually
do think that there's a way for them to
kind of get their way out of it it's
just by simply devaluing the dollar
so much that uh they use that to kind of
pay back that debt
that's correct well the debt holders are
going to be left holding the bank
that's really what it amounts to that
brings us to the 60 40 portfolio
uh is that safe to say that's not going
to be uh
going to be the standard or at least it
won't work for for the foreseeable
future
no if you're looking at a 10-year
treasury at 78 basis points
um that's just not going to work for you
right so a hundred thousand dollars
getting a seven
you know 100 000 investment getting you
seven hundred and eighty dollars a year
people just can't live on that you know
or a million getting at seven thousand
eight hundred
and i used to get you sixty thousand
fifty five thousand dollars
you could maybe live on that if you have
two million dollars in retirement et
cetera or even less than that
um so that's a real problem so people
are gonna be pushed out of that
um and that's what that's hence the
rally in the stock market even though
the economy
has rolled over you've seen that you
know you're seeing a v-shaped recovery
in
in assets and you're not seeing that
necessarily in the economy
yeah what's really interesting to me is
uh i think if you had
asked most people um okay we're gonna
have a
kind of liquidity crisis due to this
public health crisis
uh when that happens the fed's gonna
step in uh and
between the elected officials and the
fed we're gonna get a zero rate
environment and trillions of dollars of
quantitative easing
like what's gonna happen right inflation
would absolutely be part of that
conversation
and inflation hedge assets i think most
investors would say would do well
it almost feels like to some degree
equities are getting
put into the inflation hedge bucket uh
in some weird way right and some maybe
some of it people running from
uh the bond market some of it is um you
know we're sending stimulus checks to
young people
and now it's got lower barriers of entry
to get into the stock market like
how do you see kind of equities uh and
the the demand
is having such an explosion in this
environment yeah i i think it's a
natural reaction
i don't think people have thought
through where the inflation might show
up
so you could be in equities and you
could actually maybe benefit from that
and avoid the inflation because your
company was able to pass along through
prices and they could hold down their
wages etc
or you could get hit where your earnings
suddenly collapsed by 50 60
it doesn't ripple through the economy in
an even way
and that's what's coming up in the
future for for a lot of people um
and i think you're going to start to see
that now you couple that with the
valuations the valuations are
very extended for many companies and
it's hard to see
the typical stock that you know
investing through a basket in the s p
500
how you're going to get an adequate rate
of return looking out over the next
decade
i think you're going to end up with a
very poor rate of return possibly a
negative rate of return
yeah one of the um things that a couple
people have come on the podcast and
talked about in the past that i find
fascinating is this idea of
uh technology being very deflationary
right and so
kind of you can use the trend of
technology to uh continue to kind of eat
up all of this liquidity you won't see
the high levels of inflation
you'll be able to continue to drive
equity returns in those types of
businesses
how do you guys see the technology
companies and the sector
and maybe their relationship to the
macro environment so certainly in the
leading companies i would i would be
very
concerned just based on valuation you
know you're looking at apple at a two
trillion dollar market capitalization so
it's going to grow at 20
that means it has to increase it by 400
billion dollars
in size and then it has to grow by a
bigger number in year two
it just doesn't seem possible to me so
you know there's a saturation point for
a lot of technology and the fact you
tweeted out something the other day
about
apple releasing new phone my old phone's
going to slow down
so the fact that you and i may because
of that dynamic you and i may run out
and buy new phones but we're not growth
to the market
right they need to find 20 more users or
come up with better products than that
so i think just the sheer scale of that
um
is is really kind of unnerving and you
know i look at you know whether facebook
or twitter and kind of there's a
going to be backlash because of
potential censorship etc
those things don't have a lot of margin
of safety there um so
they may work uh but i don't i don't
think that's a great bet
yeah one of the things that's very
obvious just between conversations that
you and the rest of the team have had
kind of publicly
uh content you've put out etc is uh it
feels like you're not looking for the
grand slams
instead you're looking for the high
probability wins right kind of that
value investing
mentality and what i think i hear you
saying is that these technology
companies especially the top five or six
of them
just violate almost everything in the
value investing kind of framework
that's that's correct that's correct i i
think what's going to end up happening
because the
dysfunction that had gone on in the
marketplace and you know before we got
on now i was telling you that when i got
in the business
the energy sector was 30 of the s p 500
today it's 2.1 now when you think
through the implications of that
what does the energy sector truly mean
to the global economy
it's something substantially more than
two percent
and if you if i was an evil genius and
you put me in charge of all the
hydrocarbons in the world and i shut off
the spigots
in tonight everyone would come to me
looking to cut a deal and give me
whatever they needed to to basically
restart their business so when i when i
see that going on
the functional equivalent is actually
happening through
environmental concerns through lack of
investment through people basically not
giving
exploration companies the money they
need to replace the reserves
you're starting to see that basically
the the supply
is falling off a cliff and if you look
through like
typically you wouldn't see commodity
prices up in a year that we've had so
far right they're connected to the
economy
you're starting to see certain
commodities not not oil yet
but natural gas is up 20 some odd
percent why is natural gas up 25
because natural gas is really a
derivative of
drilling for oil but the demand for
natural gas doesn't fall off in the same
way
you still want to run your air
conditioners etc etc you need to do the
power plant so the supply
the same amount of oil now look at the
same amount of natural gas
and the demand is still there you see
the correcting mechanism is the price
there's a lot of deflationary issues
that have gone on in the last
six seven years as a result of the price
of oil coming down very substantially
earlier this year went negative 30
plus if the price of oil because of
a lack of supply reverses itself you
could see
inflation come back in a very ugly way
um so that would be one of the main
concerns that i would have looking out
in the world and we're positioning our
portfolios
for that potential now you don't have to
agree with us but maybe
you should have one percent or two
percent or five percent with us because
the way you're looking at the world may
not play out
in things are going to always be rosy
technology is going to grow to
you know 10 trillion dollars in the case
of apple to get it at a group rate of
return
absolutely so not only are some of the
tech companies a violation of kind of
that value investing framework uh you
mentioned bitcoin
and i think most value investors when
they look at bitcoin
would say that violates everything to do
with value investing
uh where does your interest and kind of
bullishness come
from when you're looking at that digital
asset
sure so let me uh give a little
background on how i got into it so
um back in late 2015
my colleague murray stahl who had a
brilliant financial mind
um and had a history had a degree
computer science has an interesting
photography et cetera
he had the bitcoin white paper on his
desk
and that day he came in he goes you know
what i need to read this
i'm hearing some things about it it's
only 9 10 pages long
he reads it he gets up out of his desk
he tells me about it
within no exaggeration a minute and a
half i said i'm in
okay so now why am i in i said well if
you tell me that you think that they
solve the double spend problem you can't
copy and paste and
can't spend bitcoin multiple times right
and you think that the security is
actually going to hold
in terms of the blockchain you're
telling me there's a fixed amount of
coins that are
going to be produced this could
potentially be a global currency
this is literally within a minute and a
half time and the demand for this
is going to grow exponentially but the
supply is going to be very finite
and basic economics that's
a win so i didn't get into bitcoin and
let me let me
just to show you that i'm not reckless
the way i was going to control my risk
as i as i hadn't read the paper as of
that moment i took it home that night
and read it and started doing more
homework on that
i said i can control my risk by putting
a small amount of capital
and the asymmetric nature of this
potential investment
is such that i'd be foolish not to have
an exposure to it
so i would say within probably four or
five days we had
in our accounts and personally ownership
of bitcoin that quickly
and we sized it in a way that if it went
to zero
we lose one percent if it went to zero
over two year period of time we lost 50
basis points per year
it's kind of a rounding error in terms
of performance it wouldn't be the end of
the world
but in success mode i didn't get into
bitcoin to
make 25 30 times my money which i've
already done
i got in to make many thousands of times
my money
so if i didn't own it today and i heard
the same story i would get up
and go find a way to buy it immediately
yeah
and do you guys hold it with the
assets uh that you manage or just in the
personal accounts
uh both we bought it professionally
and and when you do that what is the
kind of conversation like
uh with investors is this part of kind
of the hard asset
thesis that you have and yes you're
owning kind of cash producing land and
bitcoin's
kind of part of that thesis or is this
something completely separate um
in terms of a thesis this is something
completely there's there's no cash flow
as you pointed out right
you can't but the the true value of it
or the quote intrinsic value you can
argue about what an intrinsic driving
means
is that it has better monetary
properties than anything else
out there so when you think through i
went back and and i looked at what hal
finney said almost immediately when he
was starting to mine in the early days
of bitcoin
he made it you know hypothetical that
this could equal all of the value of the
assets outstanding which he calculated
to be
100 trillion to 300 trillion and if you
think through about what he said there
you say
yeah you know that's right that bitcoin
could equal all of the other nominal
stores of value could equal what
gold equals cash around the world
short-term treasuries short-term bonds
et cetera
and that number is staggering so when in
success mode
and and so far it's been successful in
success mold
it really should be a non-arbitrageable
thing people
should say this is a better store of
value let me get out of my yens my
dollars my euros
and move it into this so there's a lot
of data points as we went along there
in 2017 i just gave you one of the
things that i i said okay
my my lens initially was very small it
was from an economic lens
and an incentive lens and i said
you know i can see how the investment
community is going to get on to this
because the
the fees in running money through
indexation
are collapsing and the one thing i know
that wall street desires its fees
and cryptocurrency is going to offer
them that in the future so i said okay
that that's an incentive that i see that
ultimately the financial industry is
going to get behind us
but one of the things that that made me
convinced that it was going to come
along was in in early 2017
abigail johnson of fidelity right she's
she's
born into a family of billionaires she
takes over control of fidelity
investments which is highly regarded
right has a great reputation
she's very publicity shy she seems like
a completely normal person
and the first speech that she gives is
about bitcoin
okay so now i said why does she need to
do that she doesn't need to do that
right so she's the only reason she's
doing that is because she's laying the
foundation
for fidelity to get into the custody
fidelity to be recommending it to their
clients etc and you saw the report that
they came out
you know two days yesterday two days ago
about moving five percent of the
customers assets into
bitcoin and i i can see that coming in
and that wave is still in the very very
early stages
so my anticipation i don't worry about
day-to-day i don't know where bitcoin's
going to be three weeks from now
but looking out i expected to rival all
of the nominal stores of value out there
and that number is absolutely staggering
so if it got to
you know when i first made the
investment i said okay it's eight
billion dollars in market capitalization
and i said if it just got to 80 trillion
dollars that wouldn't even be all up
close to all of the nominal stores of
value out there
that would be i'm making 10 10 000 times
my money
um so that's that's kind of how i looked
at it so the asymmetric nature of what
the upside potentially could be
yeah what's so crazy is um you know i
usually walk people through the math of
let's say bitcoin's a 200 billion dollar
asset
give or take gold's 8 trillion you're
talking about a 40x
just to get to gold's market cap right
and then on the expectation that i think
you and i both have that it eventually
eclipses that
right then you start looking at things
like okay what about the global money
supply right and that kind of 80 90
trillion what about
global real estate right you kind of can
really see
um you know very very large market caps
but one of the things that i find
fascinating about it is um not only
is it oh let's just go and eclipse gold
right and kind of gold'll coexist with
bitcoin
but actually is there a world where you
start to to
uh not be additive market share uh or
market cap but actually you
are extracted to these other store value
assets right the whole reason why people
get out of dollars into
art or real estate or any of this stuff
is because they're trying to protect
their wealth right their inflation hedge
type assets and so
if i actually can just hold the bitcoin
and not have to go into those assets
could we see a contraction in some of
the store value market caps right
as there's an inflation in bitcoin's
market cap now i don't know if that'll
happen or not but it's really
interesting to start thinking about
right absolutely good um you know and
and that number grows every day as
central banks around the world continue
to print right it's going to go up
another
two trillion dollars or more it's going
to go up five trillion dollars probably
over the next year in the united states
so
absolutely absolutely yeah and how do
you see bitcoin
in the macro environment right so right
now it feels like
there's some portion of the population
who already was a bitcoin believer
investor holder whatever
uh now you've got almost the federal
reserve running this like trillions of
dollars in in marketing campaign for
things like you know gold bitcoin
whatever uh
do is this something where we see the
longer that the fed continues to do what
they're doing bitcoin just becomes more
and more attractive
or is there some you know kind of just
natural cap to early adopters
around the technology or something where
um maybe they can't continue to see the
adoption at the rate that we're seeing
right now
no it's it's you know if you speak to
somebody from brazil
or argentina argentina or venezuela they
instantly get it right because in their
own lifetime if they're my age
in their own lifetime they may have seen
their currency debates down to zero
three four times here in the united
states we're going to be
laggard because people think the dollar
you know no that's good i get my money
back it's it's
all good they don't think in in relative
terms and they don't think in real terms
in
in what their purchasing power is going
to be a decade out that's becoming
obvious
and if you're an investment professional
and the gatekeeper for that
if you're not paying attention to that
you're not doing your job right and that
that world is coming here in the united
states and fidelity's going to usher it
in and goldman sachs is going to usher
it in
you know and you know obviously people
talking about what's on the
in the treasuries of of corporations
it's four to five trillion dollars and
if you're
you're a controller for a company or
treasurer for a company or cfo for a
company
you're you need to think about that
that cash asset that i have is being
eroded at a very fast rate what can i do
to save it and when you go down the list
bitcoin makes a lot of sense yeah what
do you think it'll take for central
banks to put it as a reserve asset do
you think we can get there
you know uh it's funny to say that i i i
go to bermuda a lot
and i actually pitch the premiere of
basically
that he should take a million dollars
two million dollars and
they had a debt burden there i said this
one or two million dollar
investment could basically alleviate all
your problems you'd be the best
capitalized country in the world so um
yeah i do i think there's going to be
some intelligent finance minister
somewhere that's going to say
you know what we should own this
immediately
and get ahead of the curve and if i was
having a conversation with donald trump
i would tell him that he should tell
steve mnuchin to basically do that
so absolutely i think it's going to
happen yeah i i
uh i'm already past the point of is it
going to happen
and uh now questioning who's done it
already
right that's absolutely correct and uh
you know unfortunately for the narrative
it's probably gonna be some of the uh
the fringe
uh countries right the people who are a
little nefarious maybe under sanctions
that type of stuff
uh would be financially incentivized to
do it
first but but when you kind of get past
those
countries uh it would not surprise me if
there's one or two countries that have
already
you know again one percent of their
assets right it doesn't have to be
anything that is uh
super material but um more of that chaos
hedge type approach
uh given all of the uh the monetary
stimulus is going on
yeah i agree and that person is likely
to be go down in the history of that
country as a hero
absolutely um other than bitcoin is
there anything else that you guys are
doing in
cryptocurrencies blockchain mining and
anything else
so so we got into the mining business um
and i'm probably the fourth or fifth
person
qualified to speak about this within my
firm um so
so we're on the belief that the mining
industry
is going to be among the biggest
industries in the world and just i'll
just give you an example as to why
i say that so right now based on the new
equipment that we've purchased
and how cheaply we can source the
electricity
we can mine a bitcoin for about fifty
six hundred dollars to seventy five
hundred dollars depending on
on that so now if you think about that's
a hundred percent rate of return if the
price stayed at eleven
four i just mentioned that you know it
as well as i do the 10-year treasury
that's 78 basis points or 73 basis
points
so people are going to say you know what
i'm i'm willing to do that let me
allocate
you don't have to take a large amount of
money the machines themselves aren't
that expensive so i'm willing
to start doing that and they're going to
find people that have that capability
and seek that out and that's going to
continue to grow and you're starting you
know you see that on a daily basis with
the hashing
rate of the network itself so that
that's going to continue to be a
massively big
operation and potentially a very large
industry
and we're going to continue to grow that
got it and in terms of
uh kind of merging these two worlds so
you talked a lot about energy
uh and then now you're talking about
bitcoin uh mining there's obviously
a need for energy in bitcoin mining do
you see opportunities for kind of these
new
uh players around bitcoin mining to work
with the old incumbents
uh on the energy side or is that
something that will take a little bit
longer to start happening
now you're already seeing that so if you
go out to the permian bases
um you know they're drilling for oil and
they're flaring off the natural gas
right they're just burning it off it's
not helping the environment so
now you've seen people are bringing
trailers out there full of bitcoin
mining machines and starting to use that
energy as basically
to power their machines so that's that's
going on i don't know to the extent
um but it's going to grow that will grow
exponentially in the next five years
yeah i i completely agree um what else
are you guys looking at right so you've
got kind of the hard assets you've got
bitcoin uh bitcoin mining where else
sitting from kind of this value
investing
seat given the macro economy or are
places that are interesting to you
so uh the various financial exchanges
around the world
um so if you think about a financial
exchange generally there's a license
right there might be a clearance license
associated with that they generally give
out one or two so they're very rare to
get
and the influx
of additional money being printed up
finds its way into financial markets to
trade
so that's those are really scaled
businesses they have tremendously
great operating characteristics so the
more volume that goes through an
exchange
there's really no marginal cost of
trading additional shares it falls right
to the bottom line
um so we are you know very big investors
in various exchanges around
around the world and the thought process
there is
that those will continue to grow as
businesses and just kind of the more
financialization of everything there's
going to have to be exchanges in
marketplaces where that stuff is traded
correct correct yeah and then let's talk
a little bit uh in the private markets
in terms of venture capital
and technology companies do you guys do
anything uh there or is everything
pretty much focused on the public
entities
so it's 99.99 public
um but you know when we first found
bitcoin
we initially did it for clients uh
through
gbtc grayscale and uh digital currency
group we made a small investment in
in that company um and i would have
i did do a little personally i would
have made it a much bigger position if
they were willing to sell me that
um so uh i would say on the private side
it's done more on a personal level than
it is
at the uh from from an investment
standpoint
professionally got it and and just any
thoughts
um or outlooks there i i think that
there's been a lot of um
kind of well-known money managers who've
over the last 12 months or so
uh started talking a lot about you know
some of the most interesting places to
invest
uh inequities is in that private market
and kind of the venture capital type
model and any thoughts there as to
what's interesting or anything that
you've looked at
um so you know you actually uh were
leading me in
the direction um digital art
you know i don't know that much about it
i haven't really followed the ntf market
and how that all works um so that's my
that's on my list to look at next
um so that's potentially a big big area
so anything that's tradable um that's
going to have value is
certainly something that you should be
looking at i'll get you up to speed i
don't know if i know everything i i
might be the
the 90th or 91st best person to talk to
about it but
i'll tell you what i know now peter
this is awesome uh last question for you
before we get into kind of the final
questions is um
what about markets around the world
right so uh kind of we've talked a lot
about
the more north american viewpoint uh are
there other emerging markets uh or other
superpowers
uh markets around the world that you
find interesting or have been spending
time on
so um we have exposure to japan and you
know of interest that you know i don't
know if you know you notice that warren
buffett a number of months back
invested six billion dollars in japanese
commodity trading houses
he's obviously doing that for a reason i
think he thinks that inflation's going
to be a problem the trading platforms
are
a very desirable operating
characteristic so we have that exposure
through that we've we've found other
publicly traded uh bitcoin exposure
i i professionally bought micro
strategies in a very small position in
number of accounts so if i was
if we were entering a stock um
competition
and i had a select company that could do
the best over the next five years
that certainly would be in the category
because that the single position of
bitcoin i don't love the underlying
business itself but that position of
bitcoin could grow to some staggering
number
and and that stock could just be off to
the races so we we have a number of
companies like that
got it and uh what about square putting
uh
the bitcoin on the balance sheet it's
only one percent of assets but
um i've got to imagine that's another
kind of positive data point your
opinion absolutely you know do you there
if you're skeptic about what we're
saying
here you can kind of ignore square uh he
can lose
one percent you can you can kind of
ignore uh microstrategy
this guy's a little bit off the beaten
path you know he could be wrong he's
going to be known as that guy if it goes
south on him
it's hard to ignore fidelity investments
so when i when i saw that in 2017 it
really
you know solidified for me that this
wave is coming
and they spent the last several years as
has other firms
getting up to speed where they can
custody they can trade et cetera
and they're now going out and they're
going to recommend it and
you know we didn't talk about gresham's
law but the whole concept of
bad money draws out good good money is
bitcoin
bad money is currencies around the world
and you're seeing that basically
a lot of the bitcoin has not traded in
the last year right i think you even
tweeted something like 63
recently right has not traded in the
last year that's because people
are hanging on to it and there's going
to be a scarcity value for that and
basic economics right the first thing
that you'll learn supply and demand the
demand is going to grow
in ways that are just going to be
tremendous and the supply is very
limited so the correcting mechanism is
the price so you know
i have you know i have no doubt that
i'll wake up one morning
and bitcoin won't be 11-4 it will be
2072
and then it will be 107 000 like very
quickly
um because somebody wants to get in on
that and and there's a scarcity value
for a company like microstrategy if
bitcoin is successful
somebody's going to want to own those 38
000
so it makes them an acquisition
absolutely i tend to think that um
you know nothing is a sure thing but uh
in terms of supply and demand
there is uh very few things that have as
an attractive asymmetric
you know risk reward uh kind of
framework than uh than bitcoin right now
and so it's uh
it's gonna be fun to watch for sure yeah
and and i echo that nothing is there's
not a sure thing i'm
i'm not i don't have a degree in
computer science i didn't go line by
line on the code
you know the back door some way that
they can help me
issue 23 million i don't think that's
the case but
just you know there's unknowable and
nobles um and
you don't need that you don't need a
staggering amount right so i put you
know
personally i put two or three percent in
back in you know 2000s
now position my portfolio i'm not
selling a single one i think it's going
to
some some crazy level and i and again if
i heard the story today for the first
time knowing what i knew then
i'd say i'm in i love
that um i uh i finish up with the same
two questions you'll get asked me one to
uh to end it the first is what's the
most important book that you've ever
read
so most i would say there's probably
been
three books in my life that have been
kind of impactful uh there's a book
called spoon river anthology
um i read it when i'm pretty young by a
guy named edgar lee masters
and it's a fictitious town in the
midwest and people are writing from
their grave
wow um so it it's you know some of the
stories are absolutely beautiful
in it literally they're a page or a half
page each and then some
are just very dark and it kind of when i
was kid reading that i was like wow
people really have this
inner life that they're not going to
reveal to you so that was kind of an
awakening to me
um and then i would say that um how to
win friends and influence people has
been
an important book in my life um and
every time i think i'm acting like a
jerk i go back
and read it because i think it's such
common sense
and i think how you treat people and you
don't have to be nasty and get a lot
done that way um so that's an important
input influence
and then a company a book called
influence by robert
um just persuasion and techniques like
that so you know i follow uh scott adams
on
twitter and and some of his podcasts and
kind of puts things reframing things and
positions that you have and how to look
at the world a little bit differently
i think so you know i read most of those
when i was very young but i i would say
that those really were impactful for me
yeah those are great recommendations
i've read two of the three and
uh and very very good ones uh second
question is a little bit more fun
uh aliens believer or non-believer
um so i listened to stephen hawkins
before he passed away a number of years
ago
and um you know he thinking about the
vastness of the universe
the probability that there's other forms
of life
is probably pretty high uh so and
the more disturbing part of what he
thought was that it's probably not
looking too good for us humans the way
we treat other people um
so yeah i would say i'm a believer yeah
i'm
i'm with you i always say that we want
to find them we don't want them to find
us right
and if we find them we hope they're nice
absolutely uh you could ask me one
question to finish up what do you got
for me
so if you your wife and your brother uh
decide to form a business will you allow
me to invest be an early investor
yes
uh i uh uh they will appreciate that
question more than
more than even i will not peter listen
thank you so much for uh for doing this
um i think people will really enjoy this
where can we send people to find you
uh on the internet and also find out
more about what we guys are doing at
horizon kinetics
so horizon kinetics.com and again you
know
where we're not meant probably to be
everyone's portfolio
and we're we're saying this is our we're
staking out a position that we're
concerned about
inflationary issues that are down the
pike and we think we found
very novel ways to basically invest in
that um that even if it doesn't play out
that way we're going to get an
adequate rate of return um so
it's for the people that say you know
what we make you make a lot of sense
i'm not sure i'm going to sell my apple
or or google
but i'm going to give you two or five
percent um and you can find us at
kinetic
horizon kinetics.com awesome and then
where can they find you hopefully not
not at all i generally don't give these
um you know i i really kind of uh just a
lurker
i don't really tweet or do things like
that i
i my wife said do not talk about
politics but the reason i actually got
on twitter
um is the only social media that i'm on
is that
the 2016 election was really fundamental
and profound
in the sense that you know you had this
guy that
turned upside down but the republican
party and the democratic party and he
did it with
you know essentially twitter and a red
hat um
so that me i said wow that is incredibly
powerful so that's why
i got on that um so i it is uh
it is absolutely wild to think about
that uh these social media platforms but
when you when you break it down it's
uh the ability to communicate directly
to a group of individuals whether it's
for politics business
whatever um is just a very
powerful thing that uh changes the
the structure of how ideas are
communicated
right so you no longer have that filter
of a media organization
or somebody else kind of telling your
story or building their narrative
with your quotes um and i think that
there's good and bad
impact to that right but it's just very
fascinating to kind of watch this play
out across industries
now ken cambrie you know you tweeted
more recently about you know you don't
need
television to get your product out there
and go down the list and absolutely
correct i mean it's it's it's changed
the
life for the better i believe um but
there is some negative
but uh yeah so you know for people
listening you know
the advice that you give believe in
yourself do the work
and basically get out there and hustle
that's the secret don't don't tell
everyone the overnight secrets
all right peter listen thank you so much
for doing this i think people are gonna
love it we'll definitely have to do it
again in the future
thank you